[Music]
on the flipside of there any interviews
that you that come to mind you've had so
many but where after you're done you
just in the moments finishing the
interview think to yourself
god I hope the equipment was working
like I really hope we caught that
because it was so good out there any
that come to mind we're like wow that
was really that's one that I'm really
proud of yeah I mean a lot I think one
that sort of that I usually dust off
when I'm asked this question is one I
did after the massacre at Columbine High
School and it was for maybe 4 a.m.
Colorado time is how many hours behind
New York two or three three mountain
time to to so it was five am and it was
April and yet and so this guy was pitch
black but it was snowing so it was this
very drama dramatic scene and I
interviewed Michael Scholes who had lost
his son Isaiah and Craig Scott who had
lost his sister Rachel and they were so
broken understandably broken shattered
not even broken they were shattered and
it had happened the day before and they
came on The Today Show which i think is
always such an interesting thing why do
people in this grief-stricken state come
to talk about their loved ones I've
always been fascinated by that and
thought it would be a really excellent
thesis for a psychology student about
grief and sort of the public
acknowledgement of grief and anyway they
came and hmm and it was just a
heartbreaking interview and to witness
them kind of looking to each other for
comfort Michael Scholes was a big burly
black guy
and Craig Scott was this sort of angelic
towheaded teenager and I've actually
stayed in touch with Craig Scott and
they held hands during the interview and
it was just it was sort of the the
personification of loss and sorrow and
these two people and just holding on to
each other for dear life it was really
profound it was really I was witnessing
it less I was witness I was witnessing
it more than interviewing them you know
because they were in this particular
space and I was an observer really so I
always think about that interview as
being after it was over a really
important interview for people to watch
and I hope I handled it in a sensitive
thoughtful way that both respected them
as human beings but also guided them so
they could express themselves you know
there's situations where you just really
want people to you really want to help
them get through it I mean there are all
kinds of situations I'm sure in all the
interviews you've done there's some
cases where you know you want to afflict
the comfortable and there are other
cases when you want to comfort comfort
the afflicted and that was definitely
the latter and so just helping them
through it and that was a really and as
I don't want to say special but
significant experience for me as a
person
you